بالنسبة لي ، فإن الجمال هو
امتلاك هوية
تمسك بها شخصيتك مشتق من كلمة نوبية
قديمة تعني ولادة جديدة نريد
أن نلد مفهومًا جديدًا في
البلد والذي يكسر
معايير الجمال الثقافية
التي نحتاجها للعثور على عارضات أزياء ونساء مع
قصة لمساعدتنا في الوصول إلى هدفنا المتمثل في
التمكين بالنسبة لنا هي حركة
[موسيقى]
كانت دليلة
واحدة من نماذجنا الأولى التي احتجناها
للتركيز
قدر الإمكان على تطورها ،
وأود
تغيير الطريقة التي ينظر بها الناس إلى أنفسهم
بشكل خاص  كيف تنظر النساء إلى
الجمال حول عارضات مثلها ، أشعر أنه
دفعها حقًا إلى تلك الفقاعة من
الثقة بالنفس
[موسيقى]
لا نريد أن تكون عارضاتنا مجرد
عارضات أزياء ، نريدهم أن يكونوا قدوة
لامتلاك عقلية صحية  أهداف
لها فرص لها اختيار لنفسك
[موسيقى]